bienvenidos de nuevo este es uno de los
vídeos más importantes que van a ver en
toda su vida y es que últimamente he ido
a varias fiestas y me encontrado en
familia y bueno es de contarles que mi
esposa y yo rentamos un departamento en
el norte de california y mi familia me
pregunta que por qué no compramos una
casa de hecho me están presionando a
comprar una casa ya saben me dicen oye
sal porque no compras una casa estás en
la plenitud de tu vida tu carrera va muy
bien estás teniendo mucho éxito y fue en
ese momento en el que se me ocurrió
hacer este vídeo comparando a rentar con
comprar una casa en lo personal no he
querido comprar una casa pues estoy 100%
convencido de que los precios de las
casas van a devaluarse y precisamente
voy a hacer algunos vídeos al respecto
explicando esta situación pero bueno mis
amigos quieren comprar ellos se han
preguntado y le han preguntado expertos
si realmente es mejor comprar una casa
que rentaba una casa y una de las
razones que todos comentan es que si tú
hipotecas o pides dinero prestado al
banco para comprar una casa cada mes que
tú pagues ese dinero es como si lo
salvará
al final vas a obtener tu bonita casa al
menos esa es la percepción y cuando tú
rentas ese dinero al final va a
desaparecer en el vacío y bueno la idea
detrás este vídeo es ver si realmente
ocurre esta situación así que imagínense
que yo encuentro dos casas idénticas que
me encantan las dos están en el lugar de
mis sueños las dos tienen dos recámaras
tienen una alberca tienen sala comedor
dos baños cocina todo está padrísimo en
las dos en las dos casas
al final como las dos son casas
perfectas es indistinto vivir en una o
en otra la única diferencia es que la
primera está en renta y la renta es de
tres mil pesos al mes entonces voy a
poner aquí la primera se renta a tres
mil pesos al mes mientras que la otra
está en venta y se vende en un millón de
pesos la otra está en venta y cuesta un
millón de pesos ahora bien igual que en
el vídeo pasado voy a suponer que tengo
una cierta cantidad de ahorros voy a
suponer que tengo otra vez doscientos
cincuenta mil pesos de todos los ahorros
de toda mi vida
entonces vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa
esta vez mi primer escenario va a ser
que yo rente una casa a 3000 pesos al
mes ahora bien si yo rentó esta casa
durante todo un año es decir durante 12
meses en cada uno de los meses voy a
pagar 3 mil pesos por lo tanto al final
de todo el año voy a pagar 3 por 12 que
son 36 mil pesos lo voy a poner con
signo negativo porque esa es la cantidad
de dinero que voy a perder durante todo
el año o dicho de otra manera es la
cantidad de dinero que se va a ir a la
basura
ahora bien esperen yo tengo 250 mil
pesos ahorrados y como en esta ocasión
no estoy comprando una casa por lo tanto
los voy a meter al banco y como los meto
al banco el banco me va a dar una cierta
tasa de interés por esa cantidad de
dinero que yo estoy metiendo entonces
vamos a suponer que la tasa de interés
que me da el banco es del 4% si yo
multiplico 250000 por punto 04 voy a
obtener 10.000 pesos por lo tanto el
banco me va a dar 10 mil pesos de
interés si yo dejo todos mis ahorros en
ese banco durante un año y todo esto
para que lo estoy calculando lo que pasa
es lo siguiente yo debo 36 mil pesos por
haber rentado esta casa durante todo un
año
y el banco me va a dar diez mil pesos
por haber dejado todos mis ahorros
durante todo un año en ese banco por lo
tanto al final solamente he perdido
26.000 pesos es decir si yo renta la
casa pierdo o tiró a la basura 26 mil
pesos vamos a ver qué pasa ahora en el
segundo escenario en el escenario en el
que yo compro la casa de mis sueños y ya
está me cuesta un millón de pesos bueno
si la casa me cuesta un millón de pesos
y yo solamente tengo doscientos
cincuenta mil pesos de ahorros desde
cuenta que lo primero que necesito es un
préstamo y voy a ir al banco y le voy a
pedir la cantidad que necesito para
llegar al millón de pesos por lo tanto
el banco me va a prestar una hipoteca de
750 mil pesos porque 750 mil pesos más
250 mil pesos me dan un millón de pesos
que necesito para comprar esta casa y
bueno para continuar con este vídeo sin
tanto problema voy a hacer una ligera
simplificación tal vez en el siguiente
vídeo lo complica un poco más pero esta
simplificación me va a ayudar a entender
lo que está pasando en la mayoría de las
hipotecas cuando tú realizas tu pago
mensual la mayor parte de este pago
mensual al menos en un principio se va
en pagar los intereses del préstamo del
banco
de ese pago mensual tú pagas una pequeña
parte para bajar tu deuda es decir que
se te va a ir casi todo tu pago en pagar
puros intereses
en otro caso tú puedes pagar solamente
un cierto interés por tu préstamo pero
el interés compuesto seguiría siendo el
mismo no sé si me explique generalmente
cuando tú tomas una hipoteca de la
manera más tradicional por ejemplo a
pagar en 30 años cada mes estás pagando
un poco más que el interés que hace que
tu deuda baje regresando a este segundo
escenario voy a suponer que en nuestra
ocasión que tenemos un interés fijo
sobre esta hipoteca eso es muy
importante a lo que me refiero es que el
interés compuesto siempre va a ser el
mismo y en este caso voy a suponer que
es del 6% por lo tanto vamos a calcular
cuánto es el interés del 6% de 750.000
pesos y si yo multiplico 750.000 por el
punto 06 que es mi tasa de interés
compuesto por esta deuda que tengo voy a
obtener 45 mil pesos es decir que en
esta ocasión voy a estar perdiendo 45
mil pesos negativos porque lo estoy
perdiendo lo estoy regalando dando en mi
bolsillo por el simple hecho de verla al
banco 750 mil pesos y si yo he vivido
esos 45 mil pesos
doce meses obtengo tres mil setecientos
cincuenta pesos que yo voy a regalar de
mi bolsillo por el simple hecho de tener
esta deuda y si se dan cuenta es más que
la renta de la casa que yo tenía en el
primer escenario y bueno en resumidas
cuentas lo que les puedo decir es que en
este segundo escenario yo voy a deber
después de un año 45 mil pesos es decir
voy a perder de mi bolsillo 45 mil pesos
pero esto no acaba aquí un gran
conocedor del tema me diría pero bueno
espérate de estos 45 mil pesos que tú
estás pagando de interés por él por la
deuda que tú tienes esto se puede
deducir de impuestos y qué quiere decir
esto bueno a lo que me refiero es que
puedo ir con hacienda y decirles que ya
ha pagado 45 mil pesos en el interés de
esta deuda por lo tanto descuenten esa
cantidad de mis impuestos anuales así
que supongamos que me descuentan un 30
por ciento cuál sería mi dinero actual
que puedo salvar con estos 45 mil pesos
para esto vamos a suponer que en todo el
año he ganado 100 mil pesos normalmente
tengo que pagar un 30 por ciento de
impuestos por lo tanto tengo que pagar
de sus 100 mil pesos que gane en todo el
año
30 mil pesos que se me van a ir en puros
impuestos esto sin tomar en cuenta la
compra de la casa pero ahora si puedo
descartar los 45 mil pesos de interés de
la casa de mi sueldo por lo tanto les
voy a decir hacienda que estoy ganando
55 mil pesos y si yo calculadora el 30
por ciento de 55 mil pesos es 16 mil 500
pesos por lo tanto 16 mil 500 pesos es
lo que voy a pagar ahora de impuestos
dado que yo ya le dije hacienda que
estoy pagando una deuda de 45 mil pesos
y ahora si esos 16 mil 500 pesos le sumó
30 mil pesos que era lo que
originalmente iba a pagar de impuestos
me estoy ahorrando 13 mil 500 pesos es
decir irónicamente el pagar 45 mil pesos
solamente de interés me miden tres mil
setecientos cincuenta mil pesos
va a ser que yo ahorre del pago de mis
impuestos 13 mil 500 pesos por lo tanto
vamos a escribirlo la cantidad de
impuestos que salvo por todo este
interés son tres en mil quinientos pesos
y ahora si va tomando forma en mi
ecuación que más me falta
claro no hay que olvidar que ahora como
ya tengo una casa también tengo que
pagar un cierto impuesto por vivienda y
si yo les cuento que aquí en california
el impuesto por la vivienda es cercano a
1.25 por ciento yo creo que lo podemos
redondear en un 1% lo voy a redondear
solamente en un 1% por mi precio de mi
vivienda ojo es el 1 por ciento del
precio o del valor de mi vivienda que
por cierto como yo me quise comprar una
casa de un millón de pesos tengo que
sacar el 1% de un millón de pesos que
son 10 mil pesos y ahora si puedo decir
que el impuesto sobre la vivienda o el
impuesto sobre la propiedad o el
impuesto sobre bienes raíces o el
predial con relación a otros lados en
este caso va a ser de 10 mil pesos y
como es un impuesto es un dinero que voy
a perder por lo tanto es negativo y
ahora sí voy a acabar esta ecuación
haciendo las operaciones
correspondientes que es menos 10 + 13.5
esto está fácil es 3.5 positivo y si a
eso le restó 45.000 voy a obtener a ver
es 10 3.5 ya esto hay que restarle
35000 me va a dar menos 41 mil 500 pesos
es decir que en este segundo escenario
yo estoy perdiendo de mi bolsillo o yo
estoy echando a la basura 41 mil 500
pesos y ahora sí es bastante comparable
perder 26 mil pesos a perder 41 mil 500
pesos y realmente este ejemplo no está
nada lejos de la realidad
yo puedo encontrar alguna casa que me
cuesta una renta de 3 mil pesos y esa
misma casa tenga un valor de un millón
de pesos no estoy tan lejos de la
realidad y aunque yo redondea varias de
estas cuentas por ejemplo el tener un
impuesto de vivienda del 1 por ciento o
tener un interés compuesto fijo no soy
tan lejos de la realidad de hecho en el
siguiente vídeo voy a profundizar en
este tema y bueno seguramente el último
argumento a favor de comprar una casa
sería pensar que las casas suben su
valor pero al menos en eeuu esto no está
sucediendo es más los precios están
cayendo cada vez más rápido